en este y otros vídeos espero poder
explorar diferentes tipos de regiones en
tres dimensiones y esto será bastante
útil para pensar en cómo calcular
integrales dobles y triples y también
para algunas demostraciones en cálculo
de varias variables así que el primer
tipo de regiones las llamaremos regiones
tipo 1 ok vamos a llamarlos región es
una región tipo 1 y lo que voy a hacer
primero es definirlo formalmente y eso
nos ayudará a dar una muy buena
intuición de de qué es lo que estamos
haciendo y después vamos a dar una con
un par de ejemplos de regiones tipo 1 y
finalmente un ejemplo que no es tipo 1
porque siempre es bueno poder comparar
entre lo que sí es de lo que no es para
ver que en efecto no todas son son
regiones de tipo 1 entonces vamos a
definirlo de forma conjunta digamos una
región r
es de tipo 1 si es de la siguiente forma
es un conjunto así definimos un conjunto
de todas las ternas de números reales es
decir puntos en el espacio
tales que las primeras dos coordenadas
pertenecen a cierto dominio pertenecen a
cierto dominio de en el plano verdad son
parejas de puntos
este es el el simbolito que denota
pertenencia y ahora vamos a pedirle que
nuestra zeta por abajo esté acotada por
una función que depende sólo de xy de y
ok es decir z sea más grande que eso y
que sea menor o igual que otra función
que sólo depende de xy de ye entonces
estamos pensando que la zeta se mueve
entre la gráfica de dos funciones que
dependen de xy de y entonces un un
primer ejemplo de lo que es una región
tipo 1 lo podemos dar a partir de la
esfera unitaria por ejemplo
si tomáramos aquí nuestras nuestros xy
déjenme quito eso estuvo muy feo si
tomamos nuestros xy en en la
circunferencia unitaria ok en esta
circunferencia unitaria sobre el plano
entonces podríamos definir los valores
de z que están acotados entre una
función por abajo y otra por arriba que
esencialmente la podemos ver como la
cáscara de abajo de nuestra esfera que
es más o menos así
más o menos
y esa es una función que depende de xy
de jr correcto mientras que por arriba
podríamos definir la cáscara de superior
de esta esfera más o menos digamos si le
damos cierta cierto volumen a esto
entonces así es como podemos definir las
setas que se mueven entre los puntos
inferiores que se encuentran en la
cáscara de abajo y los superiores que se
encuentran en el casquete superior de
esta de esta esfera y por supuesto la
esfera no tenían que estar dibujada con
centro en el origen podría yo ponerle en
cualquier lugar del espacio pero para
fines de este ejemplo me basta con hacer
esto entonces otro ejemplo que podríamos
hacer y déjenme pegar los los ejes
simplemente para agilizar el trabajo
ok otro ejemplo que podríamos tomar es
el de el de los
disculpen
vamos a tomar el ejemplo de un cilindro
es decir vamos a pensar no
necesariamente tiene que estar aquí en
la base por ejemplo podríamos pensar que
nuestra base del cilindro está aquí
elevado
más o menos de esta forma que es la base
del cilindro y la parte superior por
ejemplo puede encontrarse de este lado
ok digamos que esta es la tapa superior
de nuestro cilindro entonces
para completarlo déjenme dibujarlo un
poquito mejor
ahí está digamos
más o menos ahí se ve la forma de
nuestro cilindro y entonces hay que ver
que xy que se encuentren en cierto
dominio y nuevamente nuestro dominio
servirá pues esta circunferencia de aquí
abajo
esta circunstancia de aquí abajo es el
dominio en el que se mueven tanto x como
ye y la función que acota por abajo hace
está pues es justamente la que define a
esta etapa de aquí abajo esta etapa de
aquí abajo define una cota inferior para
las setas mientras que esta etapa de
aquí arriba define una cota superior
para las setas y si nos damos cuenta
para este cilindro estamos tomando todos
los valores de z que estén por arriba de
esta etapa morada y por abajo de esta
etapa verde entonces nuevamente xy ya
está en un dominio en el plano y z se
encuentra en todos los valores posibles
entre dos funciones entre la gráfica de
dos funciones vámonos con un último
ejemplo vamos otra vez a pegar los ejes
muy bien ahí tengo digamos estos ejes
vamos a poner esos ejes y un ejemplo
vamos a hacer un ejemplo de algo que no
es no es una una este una región tipo 1
por ejemplo pensemos como en una
figurita parecida a los relojes de arena
por ejemplo ok
por ejemplo más o menos
y algo así
si me sale
algo así más o menos
y vamos incluso a darle un borde
superior curvo
más o menos
ahí está
como una especie de reloj de arena donde
esta etapa pues digamos pueda ser como
como curva y más o menos entonces vamos
a ver primero que esta región no puede
ser de tipo 1 y por ejemplo vamos a
tendríamos que tomar todos los valores
de xy de ye que pudiera tomar no
entonces más o menos toman los de esta
circunferencia aquí en el en el plano xy
mientras que los valores digamos de este
corte de este relojito de arena con el
plano xy pues son los de esta
circunferencia ok entonces porque no es
no es una región de tipo 1
bueno esencialmente si nos fijamos sólo
en esta en estos valores no es que
podamos definir de forma única este una
una
una fortuna perdón unos una función que
depende sólo de xy de y de por aquí
abajo por ejemplo si tomáramos este
punto de aquí digamos que esto fuera
parte de una de una función inferior de
una f1 nos diría que la zeta debe tomar
todos los valores entre ese y una
función superior digamos que es que es
esta no entonces hay todos estos valores
de zeta quien no están siendo
considerados por lo tanto yo no lo puedo
definir como una región de tipo 1 sin
embargo lo que sí podemos hacer es
definirlo como dos regiones de tipo 1
como la unión de dos regiones tipo 1 por
ejemplo buenos aquí quizás debería ser
más claro este ejemplo que va así
más o menos como que en realidad no es
que
se curve tanto
ahí está entonces podría definir digamos
esta parte superior
y aquí tendríamos una esta etapa digamos
vamos a pintar esta etapa
como la parte más bien sería con verde
verdad esta parte verde
esta parte verde sería nuestra función
superior mientras que esta de aquí abajo
sería nuestra función inferior toda ésta
toda esta muy bien entonces de esta
forma si es cierto si sólo consideramos
esta parte superior si la podríamos ver
como una región de tipo 1 mientras que
acá abajo acá abajo pues ésta sería
nuestra nuestra región inferior perdón
nuestra nuestra superficie inferior si
está dado por una función que depende de
xy de iu y el resto todo esto sería
nuestra creo que lo hice al revés
déjenme quitar todos esos colores
lo hice completamente al revés porque el
morado es el que va abajo entonces el
morado sería esto este es nuestra
nuestra tapa inferior
considerando sólo la mitad inferior de
este relojito de arena y con verde vamos
a poner lo que sería nuestra función
superior ok entonces esta la pudimos
descomponer en dos regiones de tipo 1
por ejemplo si lo viéramos en el plano x
perdón detalle
se detalle en realidad lo que estamos
viendo es más o menos esta figurita más
o menos algo así
o algo así
menos
muy bien
y entonces si nos damos cuenta digo aquí
me falló un poquito pero aquí esto
correspondería a los puntos morados de
esta sección de esta sección superior
del reloj y los verdes serían todos
estos verdad más o menos de esta forma
igual de de la misma forma con la parte
inferior de esta superficie entonces
estos son algunos ejemplos de regiones
tipo 1 mientras que este es un ejemplo
que no es de tipo 1